das ist schon ein wenig spooky
ausgerechnet an halloween kommt der erde
ein asteroid der wie ein totenkopf
aussieht was hat es mit der wahrheit
gespenstischen begegnung auf sich klicks
um science-fiction bei uns gibt es
täglich science videos abonniert den
kanal dann verpasst ihr kainz herzlich
willkommen ist es eine böse vorahnung
oder nur ein blöder zufall ausgerechnet
an halloween begegnet der erde ein sehr
seltsamer solid aufnahm sie tatsächlich
aus wie ein totenkopf laut spiegel sagt
rüdiger jenen vom europäischen
raumflugkontrollzentrum esoc in
darmstadt
er hat zwei dellen die man als augen
interpretieren könnte
und tatsächlich sieht dieser riesige
brocken wie ein böses oben aus zwei
riesige krater im vergleich zu dem
asteroiden prägen sein erscheinungsbild
er hat einen durchmesser von 600 meter
und mitten drauf genau wie zwei augen
positioniert befinden sich zwei krater
mit einem durchmesser von jeweils 100
metern dass sie tatsächlich schon sehr
gespenstisch aus der asteroid fliegt
allerdings in sicherem abstand an der
erde vorbei er kommt ihr maximal 38
millionen kilometern selbst den großen
teleskopen ist er kaum zu erkennen und
diese entfernung wird er auch erst am 7
november erreichen dann werden sich
wahrscheinlich zahlreiche astronomie
teams mit dem gestirn beschäftigen denn
es ist noch nicht so richtig klar ob er
tatsächlich wie ein totenkopf aussieht
2015 wurde tc 145 oder genauer 2015 tb
145 entdeckt damals loca in nur 500
tausend kilometern entfernung an der
erde vorbei um mit dem teleskop system
fensters wurde er entdeckt 2015 b145
braucht etwa drei jahre um die sonne
einmal zum mond 2021 wird also wieder an
uns vorbeifliegen das aber immer später
also immer ein paar tage später und
trotz seines gespenstischen aussehens
wird er wohl nie auf der erde
einschlagen jenen meint dazu im spiegel
er kann die erde in den nächsten 100
jahren nicht treffen wahrscheinlich auch
in den nächsten 500
nicht erzählt damit nicht in die
kategorie der asteroiden die der erde
gefährlich werden könnten entwarnung
also für 2015 tb 145 das einzige was
dieses jahr spannend sein wird ist die
frage ob er nun wirklich wie ein
totenkopf aussieht oder nicht und noch
eine frage gibt es fast vergessen was
ist das eigentlich für ein gestürmt das
wird nämlich vermutet dass es sich um
einen erloschenen kometen handelt auch
das ist eine noch ungeklärte frage also
ein rundum geheimnisvolles objekt wenn
es dazu bessere bilder gibt dann werden
wir sehen im community posten der medien
das nicht und weitere videos zu
spannenden dem verpasst abonniert krieg
vom science fiction und vergesst nicht
genau auf die glocke zu blicken wenn er
auf keinen fall etwas verpassen wollt
dann endet meine telefonnummer hier für
den whatsapp newsletter und da drunter
geht's damit weiter also dafür auch
drauf kriegen gefährlich sahst du ihn
nasa rammbock gegen ben you bis dann
flattern